the American Embassy in China has issued
a Health Alert after a consular employee
apparently suffered brain injury the US
official stationed in Guangzhou reported
strange sounds and sensations beginning
last year and later showed signs of a
concussion this case appears to be
similar to what happened to two dozen
Americans in the US Embassy in Cuba CBS
News radio Steve Dorsey broke that story
he's outside the Chinese Embassy in
Washington Steve good morning good
morning
China is offering to assist the u.s. in
investigating what happened so far only
one case has been reported in China but
what once was what was once a caper
confined to Cuba is now a global mystery
we're concerned about it it's a serious
medical incident Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo said the u.s. is committed to
getting to the bottom of what caused
mild traumatic brain injury in an
employee at the US consulate in
Guangzhou China we've notified China of
what took place as best we know it and
they have responded in a way that is
exactly the right response Chinese
Foreign Minister Wang Yi you met with
Pompeo Wednesday in Washington appealed
to the u.s. for restraint we don't want
to see that this individual case will be
magnified complicated or even
politicized he said the State Department
stopped short of calling it a sonic
attack instead issuing a Health Alert
that warns Americans in China if you
experience any unusual acute auditory or
sensory phenomena accompanied by unusual
sounds or piercing noises do not attempt
to locate their source instead move to a
location where the sounds are not
present that's the bizarre noise heard
by many of the two dozen injured
Americans based at the US Embassy in
Cuba who suffered nausea headaches even
permanent hearing loss and concussions
in response the u.s. kicked out most
Cuban embassy officials and nearly
shuttered its embassy in Havana this
certainly remains a mystery
CBS n contributor Isaac stonefish is a
senior fellow at the Asia Society even
if the US government does not accuse
Beijing of any wrongdoing it still
leaves a bad taste in people's mouths
that an American diplomat fell ill and
such a bizarre way of working in China
it's possible that sound isn't a weapon
at all but a byproduct of something else
now American medical teams are on their
way to China to examine u.s. consular
staff Americans just back from China are
advised to see a doctor if they
experience symptoms Norah all right
Steve thank you so much